chebeya claude alexis qui est avec le
code déjà eu les gens et les français
veulent savoir 2021
comment vous le sentez est ce que vous
sentez que ça va être une année
meilleure que 2020 si vous nous dites
pire on arrête tout lu ta mission
et attention on trouve tout cela est la
non écoute tu le sens pas j'ai
l'impression alors on arrête plaint de
rien d'anti la vérité qu'est ce qui se
passerait l'année en cours très très
compliqué c'est à dire pour sortir entre
les craintes étaient fondées ni pendant
minimum deux ans il faut amener à des
continents tous les cas qu'ils se
remettront passe également décroché au
niveau du monde de la restauration
donnera l'autorisation partir du
printemps sur les pour pouvoir rouvrir
en mars à peu près mars mais mars à mi
mars
c'est une prédiction voulait pas m'aider
sur deux ans dont j'ai peur c'est que
pour les restaurateurs est là là on
donne que peu sérieux c'est qui ça
arrive ça referme sa roue ça fait
maintenant au niveau des spectacles
pareil on aimerait également les
autorisations ceux qui seront les plus
touchés c'est le monde du foot en date
au niveau des stades on interdire en
tout cas le public la troupe du comme la
com ça va continuer à l'heure actuelle
et puis et mais après au niveau du
vaccin je pense qu'on n'a pas fini d'en
entendre parler parce que ces vaccins
pour moi ce sera pas c'est ce que je
ressens tension n'est pas sur
l'imaginaire mais c'est un exercice de
voyons sans équivoque ses prédictions
après il peut s'avérer impossible bien
sûr niveau au niveau du vaccin pour moi
ce vaccin ne sera pas
un peu l'écart très efficace en est je
dirais que pourrait vraiment un vaccin
qui puisse entre les cales émerger il
faudra au minimum le jeudi entre 18 et
24 mois
la contredisent les mengo celui-là va
pas et efficace et pas fin de ce que
vous voyez ne sera pas il serait pas
très efficace
et il y en a un qui est sur le marché à
l'heure actuelle de mc5 été où il ya eu
une autorisation mais qui sera retiré
d'accord c'est les prédictions de claude
a-il dit why did not c'est vrai ces
lieux des prédictions
c'est un exercice de 2,2 voilà voyant
prédictions de voyons